this is a crazy day you know for a lot
of these guys man
um but for me a year ago
today I was traded and it was
it it really felt like a bad dream to be
honest and you know I just got off I
just got off the phone with Bradley
Chubb and you know to see him smiling
and see him happy like you know it I'm
happy for him but for me
like I was so invested into the Denver
Broncos like I was so like okay it's not
going good right now but I want to be
part of the reason that we get this
thing turned around like all we need is
a quarterback we're gonna get some more
players like I want to be part of the
solution and I come into work one day
and
uh Vince Garcia I was doing Rehab on my
um on my ankle the hair trainers Vince
Garcia and Vince said he came into me he
said hey George wants to talk to you
upstairs
and I'm like
George wants to talk to me if he want to
talk to me you know usually they come
downstairs and they get you and they put
you and I was like is he gonna come down
here he's like no they want you to come
upstairs and you know how whenever it's
a move they have like the little Grim
Reaper they have like the guy like this
and he was right there I don't I don't
know his name but he's he's always there
whenever you trading the player cutting
together like you're like he ain't never
here for me
or he was there for me and I got off the
table wrote my heart started beating so
fast like it felt like I was going to
the principal office man and you I had
to walk up these stairs to get to George
Payton office and you know I get up
there I go in the room and George had
like this little button to like close
the door he pressed the button the door
closed behind me he sit down
he first he asked me you know you know
he wanted to know how I was doing how's
my ankle he said hey how's your ankle
doing I said you know ankle's good I'm
feeling all right
say that's good man you think you'll be
able to play this week and I was like
yeah you know I might be able to play
this way he's like that's good man and
then he just got straight into it he's
like well
took his glasses off when I'm down I
want to let you know that we are trading
you to Los Angeles Rams and I said whoa
like I'm like whoa
they traded to Los Angeles Rams and I
was taking
and I was like how how are they gonna
afford me they got Aaron Donald Matthew
Stafford Cooper cup Jalen Ramsey they
got Leonard Floyd they got all of these
guys I'm like bro like they got Andrew
Whitworth I'm like I'm not taking no pay
cut I'm like how they go he said well
he's like well we gonna pay we're gonna
pay the majority of your uh of your your
remaining uh salary for this year and we
just want the picks from them and we
want to put you in a good situation to
go win and you know I feel like this is
a win-win for everybody and I was like
man like it just I just felt like you
know because you get so tired to
everybody at the facility from you know
the the equipment guys to the cafeteria
ladies to the to the janitors
um to the infrastructure of the team you
know like we got a guy named Ray jackson
he and he's like player relations and
you know you get used to being around
all these guys that you know once it
once it's like taken away from you like
so quick because in free agency you get
a chance to like you get a chance to say
goodbye you know when you get traded
it's just like boom you get 45 minutes
pack up your stuff that you want to take
now and then we're going to ship
everything else to you you don't get no
chance to say no goodbye
it's crazy it ain't that ain't true that
ain't true huh what I got cut
when I got cut uh in in 17 once you get
cut you only got a certain amount of
time before you could lead the building
so like and you can't come back yeah
it's over so it ain't that much
different so so so they cut you it ain't
even like it was the conversation we had
then walk downstairs try to say goodbye
to everybody real quick and once you
walk out of that building you can't come
back it's over like and
we different though you know what I mean
because we invested you know I mean we
bought in like we we drank the Kool-Aid
yeah and once you drink the Kool-Aid
it's no I would even take a step further
and say we are brainwashed to to live
breathe Denver Broncos football or you
know Seattle Seahawk football no matter
wins losses no matter what's going on
man and I I was I was all the way in and
you know when that was when that was
taken when I wouldn't even say taken
because I end up going to a better
situation for me you know personally and
for me mentally too because once you
leave Denver from a losing situation and
then you go to La and I got Aaron Donald
and Jalen Ramsey that Odell came and we
in La like I feel like that really
brought me back like that really brought
me back I always love football like no
matter what even when we was losing I
still love football but the colors kind
of fade a little bit you know it's not
as it's not as bright as it used to be
like it's I still love it but it the
T-shirt was washed a couple of times and
then when you go to the Los Angeles Rams
it's like room you got brand new t-shirt
like I started dressing up for game like
games in Denver I just put on a white
tee some jeans and go to the football
game then you go to La and I started
trying to get fresh and think looking at
my swag and like I don't know where it
is like it just it just rejuvenated me
man if you change back on bro change
back on like has it right I'm excited
man I'm excited for to go play football
man and sofa stadium and then you come
here to the Buffalo Bills which the
Buffalo Bills have had for the last two
years they've been the most swaggiest
team in the NFL from you know digs you
know the Saran Neil to even Josh Allen
you know he'll put it on a couple of
times too so you know to come over here
and like you know have like you know
this influence man it really brought me
back but it's crazy because it changes
like people don't look at you the same
where you from and then you go to a new
team and the amount of respect that they
show you and the amount of love you be
like oh yeah yeah I am you know what I
mean oh man rich man I you know I was
with those guys so I'm with the Denver
Broncos and I'm there 11 and a half
years I've seen all these guys come in
grow up get new deals you know I've seen
guys come and go like I was just fun you
know I was just fun walking walking
around the facility like it was just fun
which was cool like it was just fun big
bro like fun then you go to Los Angeles
Rams and it's Von Miller Super Bowl MVP
like how help us win like what do we
need to think about like show us that
passwords game that you that you was
doing what are you looking at in this
when we get ready to play this team and
it's just bro it's just it really just
it really brings you back man so trades
even though it sounds like you know
they're giving you away or whatever it
is man it's when you go to a good team
man it really brings you back man I'm
happy for all of these guys and